en el último vídeo hablamos de que
cuando tratamos de maximizar o minimizar
una función de varias variables puedes
digamos imaginar su gráfica verdad y
hasta que tenemos del lado izquierdo en
realidad depende de dos variables verdad
es una función que depende de dos
variables y buscamos los sitios en donde
el plano tangente es paralelo al plano x
y una forma de imaginar esto es pensar
en el plano que representa al al valor
de z digamos a un valor constante de z
digamos un valor ce y si lo mueves hacia
arriba y hacia abajo en realidad estamos
buscando el plano que apenas intersec a
la gráfica antes de que ya no lo haga
más verdad pero tenemos otros puntos
como los máximos locales que en realidad
los podemos ver como unas especies de lo
más verdad y es en donde el valor de la
función en ese punto es más grande que
digamos en sus vecinos verdad en los
vecinos de alrededor pero también hay
cierta posibilidad de que aparece en
estas funciones y esta es la idea de
puntos y ya así que déjenme poner otra
gráfica
aquí tenemos otra gráfica y la función
cuya gráfica es esta la voy a escribir
aquí en realidad es la función f de x
que depende de dos variables también y
esto es x cuadrada menos que cuadrada
muy bien entonces pensemos quién sería
el plano tangente a la gráfica en el
origen y en realidad este este plano es
paralelo al plano xy y así se ve así que
vamos a convencernos de ello al calcular
las derivadas parciales de nuestra
función
efe entonces calculamos la derivada
parcial de nuestra función f con
respecto a x primero verdad por supuesto
cuando hacemos esto en realidad sólo
consideramos esta parte porque esto es
una constante y al derivar nos da 0
verdad entonces al derivar x cuadrada
nos da 2x verdad por otro lado si
calculamos la derivada parcial con
respecto de y ahora lo que depende de y
es justo esta parte verdad entonces al
derivar nos da
- 2 y lo importante aquí es que ahora en
realidad queremos evaluar en un punto
particular y dijimos que era en el
origen es decir en el punto xy igual a 0
0 entonces al evaluar en 0 0 esto de
aquí nos da 0 verdad 2 por 0 es cero y
esto de acá también nos da 0 muy bien a
ambos nos dan 0 y lo que significa es
que si te mueves en cualquier dirección
entonces siempre vamos a encontrar una
pendiente 0 verdad y una forma de
imaginar esto es cortando a la gráfica
ok entonces vamos a imaginar un plano
con digamos un valor constante para x y
verás que la curva donde intersecta a la
gráfica déjenme de marcarla esta gráfica
ahora tiene un máximo en el origen
verdad y de hecho la línea tangente en
ese punto verdad en la dirección y es
justamente horizontal entonces en
realidad aquí se ve como si fuera un
máximo local ahora imaginemos que la
cortamos en otra dirección digamos con
con un plano que represente
presente a un valor constante de y en
este caso vemos que la curva de
intersección se ve más o menos así
verdad de hecho tiene una forma
parabólica y nuevamente la línea
tangente en el en el 0 verdad es
horizontal pues tenemos una especie de
mínimo local de esta curva verdad y
debido a esto y a lo anterior en
realidad el plano tangente es paralelo
al plano x pero notemos que en realidad
este punto que estamos estudiando no es
ni un máximo y un mínimo local en
realidad en una dirección parece un
máximo en otra dirección se ve como si
fuera un mínimo local verdad y esto
tiene bastante sentido porque si por
ejemplo nosotros pensamos en esta
función verdad y pensamos solo
moviéndonos en la dirección x entonces
esto se vería como x cuadrada quizás más
otra constante verdad entonces esto se
vería más o menos así vamos a hacer un
poco de espacio esto se vería más o
menos así verdad se ve como x cuadrada
que es una parábola que abre hacia
arriba y por lo tanto
tenemos un punto mínimo verdad en cambio
si solo nos moviéramos en la dirección
de iu entonces ésta sería como menos
cuadrada más una constante y eso se
vería más o menos así verdad como una
una especie de para bueno es es
justamente una parábola invertida y esto
en realidad
hace que parezca que en ambas
direcciones hay como una especie de
desacuerdo de si el punto es un máximo o
es un mínimo y esto es algo nuevo en
cálculo de varias variables porque
típicamente cuando tenemos una función
de una variable pues justo solo tenemos
una dirección verdad entonces
típicamente digamos podríamos tener
nuestros ejes digamos podemos tener
nuestros ejes aquí tenemos nuestra
variable x pensamos en la gráfica de
alguna función digamos algo así y salvo
algunos casos de generados lo que vamos
a tener es que los puntos en donde la
línea tangente es horizontal pues son o
máximos o pueden ser mínimos verdad
quizás algo algunos ejemplos éste
generados entonces estos son los casos
más comunes en una variable verdad pero
aquí en varias variables tenemos la otra
posibilidad que ya hemos mencionado y
esta posibilidad es a la que llamamos
punto silla punto
muy bien y este es uno de esos casos en
que me gusta la terminología de los
matemáticos porque esto se parece
justamente a una silla de montar verdad
que sé que es la que se le pone a los
caballos para cabalgar así que en el
problema de maximizar o minimizar una
función que quizás representa las
ganancias de tu empresa
hay que saber reconocer si podríamos
tener un punto silla porque si ves
digamos la gráfica está muy bien y lo
puedes detectar visualmente pero a veces
solo tienes la fórmula y hay que saber
determinar si tenemos un punto silla sin
necesidad de ver la gráfica y eso es de
lo que habla el criterio de la segunda
derivada y del que hablaremos en el
siguiente vídeo